mais oui fameux pourra-t-elle faire
avancer la cause des autochtones tout en
jouant son rôle de gouverneur général
j'en parle avec marie goudeseune de
l'une des trois commissaires de la
commission vérité et réconciliation sur
les pensionnats autochtones alors
bonsoir mesdames ashley mon chemin alors
dites moi vous avez eu l'occasion
d'interviewer fréquemment madame simone
vous étiez vous même animatrice a subi
une hausse tout comme elle d'ailleurs
elle a aussi été témoin d'honneur à la
commission vérité réconciliation
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
cette femme de cette autochtone mais
pour commencer la sens disons que les
témoins donna on les avait choisis on
les avait sélectionné basée justement
sur un record public déjà très déjà très
impressionnant
donc effectivement je connais ces
mairies salles mais depuis des décennies
elle était à la tête des organisations
inuites au canada et à ceux le plan
international aussi les nuits seront
paul contrainte mais aussi comme
diplomate aussi et et elle était aussi
en pleine français pendant les
négociations de la constitution et les
négociations pour l'inclusion des droits
autochtones dans la constitution du
canada
donc elles étaient entretenues et
l'insee on peut le dire et même avec
quelle est question environnementaux
avec leurs titres en dessous et la
présence des inuits ou une nation unie
ou s'il a été vraiment dans les premiers
pas de tout ça alors je n'ai interviews
et à plusieurs reprises sur tous ces
sujets l'anc est une chose qui frappe
c'est que tu es toujours le peuple les
gens qui figurait le plus d'une manière
le plus important dans tout son travail
c'était pas pour des accomplissements
quand elle mais pour qu est ce que ça
pue ajouté à l'étang de la réalité de
son prix mais comment qualifier son
modus operandi est ce que c'était une
femme passionnée une femme d'action une
fan de
dialogue avant tout dialogue
oui c'est sûr je dirais qu'elle a une
force tranquille si je peux le dire elle
n'est pas et s'énerve pas facilement
mais elle n'est pas facile non plus
c'est à dire elle n'est pas molle c'est
pas une personne qui va la convaincre de
changer une question de principe
j'ai vraiment pas une personne de
principe c'est ça que je dirais et de
dialogue et de faire de son tout pour
que les gens soient respectés et que les
gens soient entendus elle s'inquiète
beaucoup à travers les générations le
bien-être des enfants l'éducation tout
ça vraiment cite une personne très digne
mais comment est ce qu'elle peut voir
son rapport au gouvernement canadien et
surtout aujourd'hui par rapport à la
couronne britannique
elle va représenter ce modèle colonial
qui a opprimé les autochtones
alors comment est-ce qu'il peut
concilier ce qu'elle a vécu un dilemme à
votre avis
mais le modèle est là que ça soit mairie
staline qui est là où une autre personne
la question c'est de savoir qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec cette possibilité là
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cet espace qui
est là qu est ce que ça a pu contribuer
au dialogue et au à l'amélioration des
relations entre autochtones et non
autochtones et c'était toujours une
position qui quittait comme des opposés
et je pense que pour une bonne foi on a
une personne qui qui vit pas d'une photo
de l'eau mais qui vit des deux côtés et
qui a bien équipées de comprendre enfin
plusieurs côtés d'une histoire est de
trouver le moyen qui est respectueux de
tous les partis - entre autres parce que
son père lui même et un britannique un
c'était c'était un blanc mais mais
dites-moi est-ce que vous croyez que son
road le devoir de réserve qui vient avec
le poste de gouverneur général est ce
que vous croyez qu'elle va sentir coincé
là dedans où elle va s'en libérer un peu
on verra on verra bien
mais j'imagine que joël vois ça comme
comme un des possibilités vaste et sans
limite je pense qu'il faut commencer un
défi comme ça toujours et de voir
revenir nos points voit son son père
comme étant un blanc du sud de
l'angleterre
je sais pas comme ça qu'elle ne voyait
pas comme ça qu'elle catégorise les gens
d'ailleurs je sais qui il a vécu la
plupart de sa vie dans le grand nord il
avait beaucoup de regards pour les gens
du nom et mairie on n'est pas une brèche
dans le grand nord c'est pas une région
où on a des réserves
ceux là où les gens vivent ensemble et
on voit la possibilité que les gens
vivent ensemble c'est pas donc c'est un
autre modèle c'est un autre esprit
d'offres de voir la possibilité des gens
à vivre une expérience qui peut être
riche pour tout le monde et pas juste
pour quelques gens qui décident pour les
autres que je pense la chose la plus
important ce que l'euro le poste du
gouverneur général saint-cricq de
l'espace donc la possibilité ou les gens
qui se mettent pas normalement
normalement ensemble historiquement
ensemble peuvent se trouver ensemble
pour avoir des dialogues ap de comium et
non pas les ans qui parle des autres
alors comme un deal à nouveau gouverneur
général aujourd'hui en acceptant ce
poste cette nomination il a dit serait
consigné c'est aussi se réconcilier avec
le passé madame oleson merci beaucoup
oui je suis d'accord avec ça la
réconciliation sera congédié césar
continuer avec le passé mais aussi avec
le présent ça c'est très important en
ville présent qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
c'est ça le défi à nous tous et ça va
être les défis pour pour denver le
nouveau gouverneur général aussi merci
mon combat la waffle